so the question is did bill clinton
visit his close friend jeffrey ebstein's
island
pedo island with two young girls new
court documents suggested in fact he did
why isn't this front page news judge
gene pierre was the host of justice with
judge dean she has thoughts on that
judge great to see you
good to see you too tucker well you know
what here's the bottom line did they
care about bill clinton when he was
engaging in sexual relations in the oval
office with an intern
no did they apologize for him yes does
the mainstream media continue to forgive
him yes
if it were a republican it would be
totally different look what we've heard
about in this
epstein case are democrats we've heard
about bill richardson
we've heard about george mitchell we
hear about bill clinton everybody says
no no bill was never on the cl
on the plane except he's on the manifest
26 times
and then we say no no he wasn't on the
island except we now have testimonial
uh evidence identification evidence by
virginia roberts who says he was on the
island with two young girls
and that evidence is significant and
they can call virginia roberts the
you know a liar till the cows come home
but she is a woman who has a picture
of herself at the age of 17 with prince
andrew's arm around her waist
in someone's home with elaine maxwell
looking at her
glenn maxwell of course now we find out
what a monster she is
because she not only arranged all of
this she
sought out girls who are vulnerable she
groomed them she taught them how to take
care
of massage men and take care of them
sexually but in addition to
all that in addition to scarring these
young girls for life
she also engaged in these underage sex
orgies she is a monster and for all
those people who said oh you know she
should get bail
no she is as bad as epstein and the
fact that she is continuing to say you
know that she didn't do anything is
absurd because there are so many victims
in this case and i got to add one more
thing tucker because i know we're short
on time
now you interviewed uh alan dershowitz
on friday
one of the things that i find stunning
is that alan dershowitz actually says
you know what it was really only two
misdemeanors that we represented him on
in florida
yeah two misdemeanors with 13 victims
and then he says you know i didn't
really know him that well except he
stayed in his house
and then dershowitz said well i was
never involved in that part of the
of the plea agreement that involved a
non-prosecution
of unidentified individuals in the
future should they ever be prosecuted
uh uh for any crimes involved with me
conspirators with me
who i suspect is gelane maxwell along
with a whole host of men
powerful rich men who as always get away
uh without paying their dues to the
justice system
yeah i mean all of us have lawyers i i
almost never invite my lawyers to spend
the night at my three homes
just you know no these are lawyers
great to see you tonight thank you so
much